alors bonjour tout le monde moi c'est
félix si jamais les lumières ferme et
hip hop à je vais essayer de continuer
d'armor pareil mais je vous garantis
rien moi ça va être bien simple j'ai
commencé par une petite énigme
puis ensuite on va essayer de les
résoudre ensemble ça va finir par une
question
puis ensemble soit on va s'y trouver la
réponse donc ça va comme suit par un
jour depuis un moine bouddhiste nommé my
désirez aller prendre une marche
il voulait pas mettre ses souliers parce
qu'il désirait sentir l'appui sur ses
pieds alors il faisait juste sortir
comme ça mais y en a quand même son
parapluie
sur leur chemin de sa marche il
rencontra son maître le maître bau mat
rebeaud parapluie à la main et sous lieu
au pied
je suis surpris de voir le moine maïs
sont ses souliers lui demanda my
pourquoi n'as tu pas mis tes souliers ce
alors qu'à ce moment là le moine confus
ne pas trop compris pourquoi le maître
lui demandait si elle lui répondit et
mes maîtres de kent m'emporter vous
votre parapluie donc li ning ses
assistants ça s'appelle leading du
parapluie qui est intéressant avec cette
énigme le sait que c'est une histoire
vraie qui m'ont été racontée par un
moine bouddhiste
suite à cette énigme le souhaite à cette
discussion le maître et retourner
étudier 11 ans en solitude bien on se
lance dans un ton juste
sans parler à personne la question est
maître mot de quelles mains porter vous
votre parapluie puis voici les choix de
réponse donc le choix de réponse à 6
lemaitre donne une réponse ne sont
politesse aux moines
parce que le moine était un peu lié avec
lui deuxième le moine surtemps se mettre
dans cette pmi comprend quelque chose
que m ne pas compris
troisième la réponse n'a aucun rapport
avec le parapluie ni la main et d
je n'aime pas les énigmes ni la
méditation c'est votre cas désolé si je
sais que je vais parler alors
tant pis pour vous un petit peu donc qui
pensent que si la réponse à ce que
voulaient voter à main levée dans le
fond qui pensent que si la réponse b qui
pensent que si la réponse c'est qu'ils
pensent que si la réponse dès ce qui se
passe mal de personnes qui ont voté la
réponse des il y en a qui ont quand même
bien baissé mais on va continuer puis je
vais vous dire c'est quoi la réponse
plus bas à la fin ça va être un peu le
fil conducteur de ma conférence moi
comment j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à
la méditation j'avais 15 ans on dira
tout avec le stress piles et la période
de crise d'adolescence différemment mais
moi à la place de m'élancer d'être belle
de faire des feux que j'ai décidé de
devenir moine bouddhiste fac durant un
an j'ai étudié les tec 10 puis j'allais
fréquenté quotidiennement un temple
après un an j'ai demandé à mon maître
qui est un mois j'ai dit comment qu'on
fait pour devenir un moins de 10
officiellement c'est à ce moment là qui
me répondu franchement je pense que
c'est peut-être point de la voix pour
toi me dis ça parce que nous connaissait
comme un bien près tout le temps là puis
pensez surtout que j'avais d'autres
expériences à vichy était différente de
devenir moine bouddhiste
après ça j'ai eu une petite période de
rupture avec la méditation fils
bouddhisme mais récemment l'année
dernière j'ai fait un jeu passionnant il
y en a sûrement qui ont déjà fait sur
dans la salle la retraite de méditation
dix jours silencieux manger les fêtes en
thaïlande
ce qui m'a surpris le plus lors de cette
retraite le sic avait non seulement oui
des voyages rapides et jacques dans la
recherche de spiritualité en quête
spirituelle
il y avait une majorité de gens
d'affaires qui était le pour prendre du
recul sur le stress qui vivent
quotidiennement
puis sur la complexité kiala qui lui
faisait face
ça m'a vraiment intéressé puis je me
disais mais pourquoi dans le fond si les
gens d'affaires ont besoin d'être ce
pourquoi il ya une majorité de gens
d'affaires
c'était peut-être juste un add on mais
ces deux titres ce qui m'a mené à
pousser mes recherches un peu plus la
méditation c'est prouvé que ça réduit le
stress s'est réduit le sentiment colère
de dépression d'anxiété et de confusion
quand c'est pratiquer quotidiennement
dont études ont prouvé que les
2 lors des situations stressantes ont
non seulement un tout cortisol qui leur
donne du stress qui se retrouve on peut
la prendre dans la salive c'est pour ça
que c'est marqué salvary cortisol non
seulement au niveau de cortisol mais
aussi au niveau d'anxiété plus beau que
les gens qui sont pas des leaders
ce ça veut dire que la méditation en
quelque sorte n'a pu approcher de
prendre d'édition comme les vrais
leaders font comme les deux qui gère
beaucoup de complexes type de stress le
fond la méditation c'est un mineur aussi
la capacité de concentration et ça
augmente la satisfaction au travail
80% des décisions qui sont prises par
les socios sont faites en 9 minutes
pensez-y neuf minutes pour considérer
tout c'est quoi les meilleures options
considéré c'est quoi les meilleurs
points comment je fais pour prendre la
meilleure décision
c'est sûr qu'il faut rester concentré la
méditation ça peut nous aider à son
trône
ça permet aussi aux maires contrôle sur
les pensées où je veux en venir en dix
ans se sait que 50 % le temps on y pense
peu concentrés sur ce qu'on fait on y
pense souvent mené nos problèmes du
travail à la maison nos problèmes de la
maison au travail
on y pour focus est sûre qu'est ce qu'on
fait la méditation ça permet
d'encapsuler le moment présent pour être
capable de vraiment pour se laisser
déranger par d'autres pensées finalement
ça permet une meilleure vision
d'ensemble 6,6 donné le psy statistiques
le luis et des données scientifiques et
tout mais ce qui est intéressant si ça a
été repris par des magazines comme
forbes puis comme le rapporte business
suis vu que publié récemment un article
comme quoi la méditation pouvait vous
aider à résoudre les conflits en
entreprise ensuite il y aussi des
gestionnaires on connaît tous steve jobs
steve jobs méditer régulièrement
c'était vraiment une pratique qui aimait
faire puis consultant mon maître zen
régulièrement cette idiotie steve jobs
dit que les produits à pau sont inspirés
du cmj possible a remarqué médias juste
un bouton
si toutes lignes sont épurées c'est très
simple ce ça veut dire en quelque sorte
que tout les gens qui utilisent des
produits à pau m2i la méditation d'une
certaine manière c'est ce qui est
derrière un peu tout ce soit sinon sur
mars
file job et on s'est dit si ou quand la
compagnie la plus innovante en 2014 le 6
octobre puis les former sur monsanto
qu'il faisait c'est pas des deux pics et
pas nécessairement aussi des gens qui
sont en quête de spiritualité qui vont
méditer c'est les gens qui désigne les
produits que vous utilisez à tout les
jours puis que vous aimez tant ya plus
de 1500 rapport depuis 1930 qui ont
corroboré ces statistiques ces données
là avec la méditation
ceux ci on a que parler des trucs qui
font affaire pour le milieu des affaires
d'enfants pas aussi parce que la
méditation ça peut aussi aider pour les
problèmes de santé comme la réduction de
l'incidence des maladies cardiaques
la réduction l'insomnie mais aussi
l'augmentation de la confiance en soi il
ya même une étude nationale des sciences
qui a prouvé que la méditation pouvait
réduire arrêtés voire même renverser les
effets du vieillissement sur le cerveau
c'est pas n'importe quoi
plus proche de nous maintenant il ya le
programme complexité conscience et
gestion à l'université laval qui existe
depuis 15 ans qui introduit les
gestionnaires à la méditation pleine
conscience
15 puis depuis tout ce temps le sujet il
faut encore face à des préjugés qui font
encore face à lyon 2 il ya toujours un
travail à faire même s'ils ont réussi à
changer la vision plusieurs personnes
j'ai vraiment bien ces dix citations le
de madame cartes et jpj qui dit je ne me
ferai pas pousser des restes à je ne
veux pas sentir le patchouli
c'est drôle parce que quand je parle de
méditation c'est souvent la réaction que
j'ai l'impression que car j'en parle aux
gens les gens perçoivent comme le gueux
qui est enroulé assis avec un chandail
tie dye pis les cheveux longs ou encore
que les gens me perçoivent un peu ce que
comme presqu'île pour une maladie mais
quelque chose qui est un peu pesante et
comme s'il veut y avait quelque chose
qui fonctionnait pas trop avec lui on
considère qu entraîner notre corps
quotidiennement c'est important pourquoi
on considérait pas entraîné une autre
esprit ce le serait ça dit tout ce que
vous dites tous quelque chose d'un
esprit sain dans un corps sain que ça
veut dire quoi un esprit sain pour vous
est ce que ça veut dire de laisser que
est riche enfin nous confère 50 % de
notre temps pour réfléchir à ce qu'on
est en train de faire ce encore plus
pesant quand on considère que la mise
a sion il ya des attitudes qui ont
prouvé que ça pouvait aider l'innovation
en organisation une étude taïwanaise ont
montré que la méditation eide a amélioré
l'intérêt de l'ouverture à
l'apprentissage ce qui influence
directement l'innovation en organisation
que la performance organisationnelle
la pétrolière basée tout un programme
neuf ans que sur la méditation et du
technique de méditation la pétrolière
shell s'est pas non plus des compagnies
comme l'oeil comme le lait je serai plus
proche du yoga ou d'autres types de
méditation comme ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est que la méditation ça permet
une certaine forme de insight qui est au
coeur du processus de la créativité et
d'innovation
ça permet de créer à l'intérieur de soi
une capsule de réflexion où est ce qu'on
peut penser sur nos pratiques
manageriales afin d amener des nouvelles
puis de les transformer aussi innovation
en enfants le but un peu et j'ai géré la
fin avec la méditation samnick
d'innovation de rupture de faire de la
méditation un outil qui est décloisonner
des préjugés des rites religieux
pourquoi pas ça pourrait très bien se
voir le moment vous attendent ici je
vais vous donner c'est quoi la réponse à
l'énigme un peu plus haut le sucre
répondit si la majorité des gens vous
aviez raison sa part rapport ni avec la
manie avec les souris mais ce qui est
important c'est le moment présent la clé
de la méditation si pour si peu d'effets
à brûler de l'encens d'intention
l'indien par terre c'est pour dans les
foires de retraite de méditation la clé
c'est seulement le moment présent si les
études ont raison ça prend que 10
minutes par jour on voit les effets de
la méditation dix minutes par jour le c5
brossage de dents 10 mai les gens en
moyenne pensée 40 minutes par jour sur
facebook
quarante minutes par jour si ça veut
dire que vous prenez encore de votre
tante facebook pour méditer dix minutes
sursis trois stations métro on peut
méditer dans le métro on reprend la de
dormir un peu personne voir ensemble
quand on va pas voir leurs besoins
la seule chose que ça prend pour méditer
c'est le souffle
vous avez pas besoin de rien donc pour
commencer à me
que vous concentrer sur votre
respiration ça fait des millénaires que
cette technique est utilisée pour aider
les moines puis d'autres personnes a
investi focus et puisqu'on centre
hippique est ce qui représente plus le
moment présent que votre ce flux lui
rien qui est autant automatique que vous
pouvez contrôler que votre souffle moi
ce que je fais pour me dit et je veux
vous dire c'est quand même bien simple
on commence avec le sushi demande si on
compte les respirations donc en
inspirant et un et deux et trois et
quatre
puis même chose en expirant et un et
deux et trois et quatre
je sais qu'il doit avant tout le monde
qu'ils sont en train d'essayer nos peurs
je vais pas vous l'imposé parce que
c'est pas un seul but mais c'est quand
même drôle parce que c'est le feedback
que j'ai eu c'est pour dire que moi je
te quitte sur du lâche un gars qui est
bouillant j'étais un gars d'action
que kim sont à entreprendre des
affaires sociales approche changé même
avec dix ans de méditation j'ai tout
essayé les forme de méditation
je dis ici le yoga c'est déjà ici la
méditation marché j'ai déjà ici le
balayage corporel
j'hésite tout fait mais celle là c'est
le plus sain ce qui a changé c'est pour
moi c'est ma vision des choses
si ma vision du monde les plus beaux
hommages avec les méditations c'est
quand je me rends compte de tout chemin
que je flippe de tout chemin que j'ai
parcouru delà des sacs comprenez poster
quoi à la personne qui tenterait d'en
faire une conférence pour terminer
j'aimerais juste se finir sur is it
works chat est ce que ça vaut la peine
d'essayer
la méditation ci pourra
ouais c'est s'impliquer au moment
présent puis ça fonctionne toujours
alors je vais continuer c'est pas ça
vous dérange
non ok hésite workshop c'est surtout si
que ça vaut peuvent guérir de rien on
l'a vu avec steve jobs demande y consent
pareil même si minutes à tout les jours
et si plus quand on considère que des
entreprises comme google apps ont pu
target qui ont mis la méditation dans
l'horaire quotidien que j'attrape ça
peut amener quelque chose
si la méditation avec le source avait
pas il y en a d'autres que plein
d'autres techniques pour mieux pour
méditer il ya des techniques même que
les gens appellent pas de la méditation
qui contenait à la méditation
moi j'aimerais se terminer avec juste
une question qui est possible sinon kg
c'est qu'est-ce que vous perdez a essayé
la méditation
ce que vous perdez h et la méditation
c'est probablement tout ce que vous avez
à gagny merci